the role of the product manager has
changed dramatically in the last few
years
traditionally it was just focused on
execution making sure that the Train is
running on time now the product manager
has become the mini CEO of the product
the chief product officer role is a
recent invention it's a recent
development that we're seeing but this
is where businesses are going we will
see more and more chief product officers
in more and more companies and we'll see
more and more people who are growing up
and they want to be product people and
we're here to help define what that is
the product manager today needs to be
good at strategy not just product
strategy would also corporate strategy
and making sure that they are aligned
making sure that the customer gets the
most positive experience the product
manager needs to get very deep level
insights about the customer at various
stages of the customer journey the
product manager has to be effective at
decision shaping shaping others
decisions especially of key stakeholders
within one's own organization many of
whom are risk-averse it's the first
program targeted at emerging chief Park
officers with a lot of product
management experience who have their
eyes set on evolving into the c-suite
executive and the program is intended to
provide the right kind of skill sets the
right kind of frameworks the right kind
of real-world experiences to make sure
that they become more effective as they
emerge into the season our program has
both an in-class component but also an
out-of-class component that forces our
participants to go out there and
actively listen to customers in the
context of a workshop and
come back and actually create products
based on that listening process to
customers
let us not ignore the fact that we are
in Silicon Valley and they will get a
chance to get exposed to the Silicon
Valley mindset as well the chief product
officer is not simply managing the
product but it's also coordinating the
development and the management of the
product within the organization all the
way up to the c-suite this is not just a
product manager but it's really a
product leader this program is intended
for those people who want to be the
product leaders in their front it is a
long-term relationship that we are
trying to create with future leaders in
the world who are going to make the
difference I mean all we can do is
provide the spark and as the leaders
were to go there and have the impact
[Music]